my guest tonight has starred in numerous
films including old school Legally
Blonde and bottle rocket that's just a
that's just to name like 1% of his
output starting May 19th you can see him
in the CW series DC star girl please
welcome
Luke Wilson Luke how are you hi Conan
I'm great good to see you nice to talk
to you and I think you're doing a real
service by helping put people in a good
mood so thank you well I like to think
that I'm the real hero in this crisis so
thanks for pointing that out you know I
appreciate it we're where are you right
now can you show me just a little of
your atmosphere I want to get a sense of
what it's like look in quarantine look
that is a lot of chopped wood that's
quite a bit oddly enough hugh jackman
split all that for me that's one of the
nice things the way Hollywood's kind of
banded together I don't even know the
guy but I mean is there anything he
can't do he can sing he can dance great
actor you don't even know him you don't
know the man I don't know the man Cohen
and he showed up whipped his shirt off
and you know he's built like you he's an
Adonis
yeah he's spent the better part of an
afternoon sweating a quart of wood for
me I just I grabbed a glass of lemonade
and just kind of took it all in it was
just kind of amazing Wow no well you
know look he's known to do that and good
for him and a shout-out to Hugh Jackman
for just randomly cutting firewood for
celebrities you know Luke I worry about
you are you staying busy you know you
look alone there and that bungalow how
are you keeping busy I've been just
trying to kind of do what everybody else
is doing which is yeah just kind of stay
but yeah it's fine oh I'll have these
conversations with my mother who's 80
and lives in Texas and she'll say you
know what did you do today or what did
you do this week you know what did you
get done and I'll say well not I've got
a little work done and made a few calls
but there
not much you know because I've just been
following the you know the state
guidelines and she'll kind of imply that
I'm kind of being lazy am I not doing
anything and getting out there that's
you know it gives me this feeling like
she's like John Gotti or like Tony
Soprano she wants me out there earning
you know it's like a pandemic paid me
global crisis my money
she takes kind of a tougher approach to
all this but no she actually she's been
doing well and she's not been asking me
for money she's yeah well let me ask you
this you know everyone's obsessed with
the same thing which is none of us are
really getting haircuts if we're getting
them like I've trimmed it some on the
sides but it's getting real floppy on
top what are you deciding to do yeah
well I mean you've your hair has always
been a big thing since you got started
and it's always had a lot of volume a
lot of body but for me it's like I
always wait till I get a job to get a
haircut
so yeah I've been having the same
problem everybody else is it's like I
did wait I did wake up one morning I
looked in the mirror and I was like I
got Chris Gaines haircut you remember
when Garth Brooks had his grunge
alter-ego Chris Gaines who got like a
cut it was like a comforter fide Kurt
Cobain that to wake up one day and you
know people talk about waking up and you
know I looked in the mirror and it's
like I didn't know who I was I looked in
the mirror and I was Chris Gaines and it
shot the hell out of me that's not a
good feeling so yeah I might have to
just yeah invest in some Clippers you
know I heard a story about you and I
don't know if it's true
but it sounds like you this is not a
good intro I'm not loving this he's
never in well apparently there was a
series of murders no I'm kidding this
sounds very Luke Wilson to me that you
once ran the LA Marathon on the spur of
the moment with no training and no rest
is that a
fake story or is that real it wasn't the
spur of the moment we decided that night
at about I'd say 3:30 in the morning
that we would make our way down to the
starting line at 7:00 that morning and
tried the race but no it's we just got
into town and me and this friend Danny
find it we've had a rather robust
evening and got to talking where most
guys would say hey tomorrow yeah we
should go down and watch the marathon we
should we said let's run this damn thing
let's let's show these guys who we are
and it's like I can't really imagine any
of the great Kenyan and Nigerian runners
deciding at the spur of the moment last
minute hey let's close down this bar go
get a couple burritos and then make our
way to be to the start line of the LA
Marathon but that is what we did I
didn't finish it but I made it I made it
22 miles really you ran 22 miles with no
training and no rest hung over it sounds
like yeah I don't hit the hungover phase
yet so that might have been what kept me
going those 22
yeah it's still there there's a
jack-in-the-box on Sunset and that's
where I kind of took my last steps and I
walked in there and got some food and
then I had to just lay down on the
sidewalk and this woman very kind woman
marathon fan laid one of those silver
blankets over me and then and then I
picked up my a friend but yeah I don't I
don't recommend doing that but it is
that kind of can-do spirit that we had
back then that I worry that sometimes
the Millennials today don't have like I
can't really see them going out doing
the marathon with no training I think a
big criticism of young people today is
that they don't have frankly the guts to
drink until 3 o'clock in the morning and
then go run a marathon and then collapse
in front of a jack-in-the-box they don't
have that spirit that I think our
generation has sometimes to be
courageous you have to be a dumbass
Conan that's that's tombstone material
not for me but yeah that's good now let
me ask you something
Luke you you do not have children
yourself but you are an uncle and I look
at you and I think that's a guy who'd be
a fun uncle are you a fun uncle yeah I
think I am a fun uncle I mean all one's
got two great little boys or make five
and eight then my brother Andrew has a
ten-year-old daughter and I I get along
great with them
yeah really fun kids I mean during this
pandemic I mean I did it is a little
like The Shining at times I did have
kind of a shining type moment with Owens
son Ford where I was saying you know I
love you the only afford very good boy I
got real weird didn't it what's your dad
been saying about me you can tell me for
oh no I get along great with those guys
they're great little kids and yeah
definitely the kind that make me want to
have some kids in my own which I should
get on sooner rather than later
I'd put it off for a while if I were you
yeah put her off I mean
Anthony Quinn you know he had a child
when he was he I just don't want to be
one of those dads it has to pay somebody
in the in the neighborhood which I feel
like I see yeah I'm at that stage but I
just did it out of laziness yeah I
wanted a really tight spiral so I I
hired someone who knew what they were
doing
let me ask let me ask you you're now
starring in this superhero series it's
DC star girl are you did you grow up a
comic book guy I mean I was really a Mad
Magazine guy that was like the first
thing I remember really getting
organized to do was to get a
subscription to Mad where okay I gotta
put 12 bucks together and and fill out
the form and and so yeah I was really in
demand I was watching him I got a damn
ad was great and if you're and if you're
in a bind yeah you read Kraft did you
ever get to that position
cracked was like okay I've read this Mad
Magazine like five times so all right
I'll go and take a look at the cracked I
won't buy it but all right
he asked and look at it yeah I really
did have fun getting into the superhero
world I mean it was it was I did have
trouble like there's so many characters
like you know villains and supervillains
and villains that used to be good and
bad like when we were doing the show
Breck Basinger in place my stepdaughter
star girl and she's a great actress and
such I went into the project thing I'm
gonna kind of teach these kids how it's
done hopefully I'll get to show them
some of the things I've learned from
some of these great actors over the
years you'll be like Brando in The
Godfather hi T telling Pacino and Duvall
you know you'll be showing them the
ropes that's really how I thought it was
going to be
I got there and then all these kids are
such pros I mean really nice kids but
also so well organized and they you know
Breck for instance you know she knew not
only her dialogue but my dialogue so I'd
get kind of mixed up with these
superheroes and we'd be doing a scene
and that said okay look we've got to get
the Iceman's lair right now and she'd
say what about icicle and I'd say look
we got to get the icicles wouldn't even
they wouldn't even cut and you know
they're you know there'd be scenes where
we'd finish doing something and I'd have
to go up to Breck and say look I'm sorry
I I always get Johnny Thunder and
Hawkman mix for some reason they sound
the same to me and she'd say no that's
okay I've just got to go do some strut
stunt training for three hours Luke so
that's great but yeah sometimes I get a
little mixed up and the the DC Comics
superhero lore and the names is it true
that you you have a little bit of a
reputation on set for maybe sometimes
going into your dialogue a little early
no my my the kid playing my son trailer
man oh this really funny great kid I
overheard him saying one day to Brack
like yeah you got to be really careful
with Luke don't take a pause because
then he'll just start talking and I said
hey by the way I don't know your
dialogue
I just don't know mine so if I see you
stop talking I'm gonna start in on my
dialogue so you got to be quicker off
the trigger and then I tried to just
kind of turn it into a thing and
remember this is the DC Universe think
guys are moving fast
ya know we gotta have that it's like a
lot of action so you got to be ready but
then you know you look around and
there's the crew watching you having
this kind of argument with the 12 year
old and but no Trey Trey Trey is one of
my good friends but he did he did
complain how he couldn't take a pause
and I said hey buddy I'm just telling
you right now I see you like look out
the window or look down at the ground
I'm coming in hot with my back
you either get it support kid the word
seems where he'd be just doing this kind
of rapid-fire dialogue you know you
gotta watch it because for years we've
been doing shows at Comic Con and those
people take this universe or any
universe very seriously and if you're
playing a character and they run into
you they expect you to know everything
about this DC Universe believe me I've
had to like watch myself I've had people
come up and say hey I hear you're in
star girl on said yeah it's it's a it's
a really great show and then the guys
say well you know this brain wave is she
ever gonna do battle with our class and
I'll say I'm not quite sure like I'll
see it in their eyes that they know that
I don't know what I'm talking about
completely uncomfortable but you know it
would be like saying like yeah I'm a
Yankees fan and then someone say like be
like Derek Jeter and said yeah my best
to get better but yeah I really try and
keep those conversations very brief and
say you know just do the thing hey I
don't want to spoil anything for you
about the show you'll just have to watch
my advice to you Luke is shoot your
scenes and then get back to the bungalow
as quickly as possible around if someone
might ask you a question okay that's
ghost on the set alright let make sure I
get the word out on this DC stark girl
premieres May 18th on DC Universe and
May 19th on the c-w Luke you are always
a really funny loose hang I always enjoy
talking to you you're I don't know why
we're not best friends it confuses me
let's work on it
but why should it take work what did you
say have to say it like that for that's
a good point as soon as this all over
let's get this beautiful thing started
yeah yeah you're acting well okay when
this is over when this pandemics over
we'll really start to grind
as soon as this is over light the fuse
of this dynamite of friendship that's
gonna take over West West LA
oh yeah oh yeah well I'm very excited
about listen so nice to talk to you
great really fun to watch you guys at
night it's got to be fun for the people
out there on the front lines to have a
laugh so really appreciative to be able
to watch you at night so thank you Conan
thanks for having me on I appreciate it
and I had all your crew and Andy and
hope you guys are all staying safe we
are and thank you for those good wishes
and say hi to hugh jackman when he comes
by to get the hair out of your drain all
right hey take care of Luke take it easy
Thanks